T
FORMAL NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGY IDENTIFIES CHINA AS
AMERICA'S MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
GEOPOLITICAL CHALLENGE.
CNN'S SELINA WANG LIVE FROM
HONG KONG, WHAT ELSE DOES
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S DOCUMENTS SAY?
>> CHRISTINE, IT IS 48 PAGES IT
LAYS OUT --
IT MAKES IT CLEAR THAT IT IS
CHINA THAT IS THE LONG TERM
CHALLENGE.
IT SAYS WHILE RUSSIA POSES THIS
IMMEDIATE THREAT WITH ITS
BRUTAL WAR AGAINST UKRAINE,
CHINA IS THE ONLY COUNTRY WITH
THE INTENT AND INCREASINGLY,
THE POWER TO RESHAPE THE
INTERNATIONAL ORDER.
U.S. CHINA RELATIONS RIGHT NOW,
THEY ARE THE WORST POINT IN
DECADES.
WHILE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS SAID THAT IT DOES NOT SEEK
A NEW COLD WAR, HIS VISION DOES
LAY OUT A WORLD WHERE AMERICA
AND ITS ALLIES ARE IN
COMPETITION WITH CHINA.
>> WE ARE SEEING A VERY RARE
SITE IN BEIJING.
WE ARE SEEING THESE PUBLIC
PROTESTS AGAINST CHINA'S
HEAVY-HANDED COVID RESTRICTIONS,
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
>> THERE WERE TWO BIG BANNERS
HUNG OVER A BUSY OVERPASS IN
BEIJING.
THE VIDEO, YOU CAN ALSO SEE
SMOKE COMING FROM THE BRIDGE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SOURCE
OF SMOKE IS.
ONE OF THE BANNERS READS THIS,
CHRISTINE.
QUOTE, GO ON STRIKE YOU A
DICTATOR AND NATIONAL DICTATOR.
THERE IS A SPEAKER WITH AN
UNIDENTIFIED VOICE READING THE
BANNERS.
THIS MAY SEEM LIKE A FEW
BANNERS HUNG IN THE CAPITAL,
BUT I CAN'T OVERSTATE JUST HOW
RARE AND EXTRAORDINARY THIS IS.
TO HAVE IN THE CAPITAL, NOT
JUST OPPOSITION TOWARDS ZERO
COVID, BUT TOWARDS SHE JINPING
HIMSELF.
IT IS COMING AT SUCH A
SENSITIVE TIME.
WE ARE JUST DAYS AWAY FROM THE
PARTY CONGRESS, XI JINPING IS
EXPECTED TO STEP INTO AN
UNPRECEDENTED THIRD TERM AS
CHINA'S SUPREME LEADER.
THERE WAS ALSO ANOTHER BANNER
THAT READ QUOTE, SAY NO TO
COVID TEST, YES TO FOOD, NO TO
LOCKDOWN, YES TO FREEDOM, NO TO
LIFE, YESTERDAY AT THE, NO TO
GREAT LEADER, YES TO VOTE.
DON'T BE A SLAVE, BE A CITIZEN.
WE HAVE TALKED BEFORE ABOUT
THESE PUNISHING ZERO COVID
POLICIES IN CHINA WHERE ENTIRE
CITIES ARE STILL BEING PUT
UNDER LOCKDOWN OVER A HANDFUL
OF COVID CASES, CLOSE CONTACTS.
CASES ARE SENT OFF TO
GOVERNMENT QUARANTINE
FACILITIES.
WE HAVE SEEN GROWING DISSENT.
IN TERMS OF THIS INCIDENT, WE
DON'T KNOW IF ANY ARRESTS WERE
MADE.
BUT PUNISHMENT FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS COULD BE SEVERE.
THEY COULD FACE PRISON T